- I don't take the same suggestion twice,
cause that would cheating.
All right.
- [Woman In Audience] Racism.
- One second.
(audience laughs)
One second.
And what a real great first
suggestion just straight in.
(audience laughs)
Just, just, like, "Racism!"
Out the bat.
Yeah.
Straight away.
One final rule,
(audience laughs)
and that was an acceptable suggestion.
I will grill you further on it, though.
Who over here said racism as a suggestion?
- [Woman In Audience] I did, I'm sorry.
- No no.
You don't need to apologize for that.
I mean, what aspect are
you coming from?
Are you like, "It's a great thing!"
"I love it!"
(audience laughs)
Let's, it's a very general topic,
so let's delve into it.
Like, pick an aspect.
- [Woman In Audience]
(inaudible)...of American History.
- (laughs) I think that, you know,
we're gonna need more
than a three minute beat
to tackle that, and this
is only (crowd laughs)
one of five topics.
- [Woman In Audience] But
this is Black History Month,
and it's the last day.
- It is Black History Month.
It's true, it's the leap day.
It's the once every four years
Black History Month gets one extra day.
It does feel unfair that
it's the shortest month
of the year, doesn't it?
Really.
I don't know.
Okay, cool, so--
- [Woman In Audience]
Let's deal with that.
- Let's deal with that.
I'll deal with it, obviously.
I feel like you've just gone,
yeah, handle this, white boy.
But that's fine.
(crowd roars with laughter)
That's a fine suggestion.
So, a history of racism in America.
(laughs)
And let's get, we need
four more suggestions,
and let's come to you guys over here.
What do you want a rap about?
- [Woman] Sex.
(crowd laughs)
- Have you not heard enough
hip hop songs about that already?
I mean, let's be specific.
Let's be like, pick a
position like reverse cowgirl,
or, be like, oh that awkward moment
when you have to check
if the condom's still on
because you're not sure
you want to be a dad,
or like--
- [Woman] That one.
- No, not one that I've said.
That would go against the rules.
Guys, I know it's late, but
step your game up, really.
What do you want?
- [Second Woman] She's a sex-ed teacher.
- [Chris] You're a, oh.
(crowd laughs oohs)
Sex-ed teaching, that's a good suggestion.
What's your favorite thing,
well, what do you think
the most important thing to
teach our kids is in sex-ed?
- [Woman] Right now I'm
teaching safe pornography use.
- [Chris] Safe pornography use.
Guys, cancel the show,
we're all gonna learn something.
(crowd roars and claps)
So, safe pornography use in the context
of a healthy relationship?
Or, just in these kids lives?
- [Woman] Healthy relationships
and not becoming addicted.
- Yeah, yeah, it's a hard problem.
That wasn't--
(crowd laughs)
That wasn't on purpose, guys.
Okay, safe pornography use.
That is a fantastic suggestion.
What a moment for you to walk back in.
We're learning about
safe pornography usage.
(crowd laughs)
You're like, I don't
need to learn about that.
I'm all written up, I know that.
So, we have the suggestion a
history of American racism,
safe pornography usage.
The rest of you who have to suggest
have a real tough part.
There's a hand in the
back waving very politely,
and I'll come to you second.
Person in the back, what do you want?
- [Woman In Back] Growing
up in a funeral home.
- Oh, wow.
That definitely feels that it comes
from personal experience,
but then again, you're
not wearing all black, so,
did that happen to you?
- [Woman In Back] Yes.
- Yeah?
You seem quite cheerful and normal.
(crowd laughs)
It's like yeah, you
should meet my brother.
Eugh.
(crowd laughs)
Growing up in a funeral home.
You had a hand up here.
- [Man In Front] Yeah,
someone cuts you in line
but they're in a wheelchair.
- Someone cutting in line,
I don't feel that gives them a pass.
They get their own fucking parking spaces,
they can wait in line as well.
Plus, they get to sit down, it's comfy.
Sorry if you're in a wheelchair,
but also, get the back of the line.
Right, so, a history of American racism,
safe pornography usage.
Someone cutting in line,
but they're in a wheelchair,
and growing up in a funeral home.
There's one suggestion that
I feel like should come
from the middle of the room,
cause you guys have yet to--
- [Woman] Who loves Kanye
- [Man] Changing a tire.
- [Woman] More than Kanye?
- Whoa, one second, there
were two at the same time,
so the gentleman said?
- [Man] Changing a tire.
- Changing a tire.
You're quite drunk aren't you?
You said, trainging a tire.
Trainging a tire, yeah.
(crowd laughs)
And I--
- [Woman In Crowd]
That's what I'm here for.
- One person is super excited
about changing a tire.
Can I just clarify, so,
you mean as in, a rubber
tire on a vehicle,
or attire as in clothes?
- [Man] Tire for a vehicle.
- Cool cool, cause like a change of attire
could also be when you go, yeah yeah.
No, I just wanted to check.
I didn't want to disappoint you,
when I'm like kind of, I got a tuxedo,
and you're like, ah,
no, I wanted Michelin.
Right.
(crowd laughs)
And then, there was a woman's voice
that said something as well.
- [Woman] Who loves Kanye more than Kanye?
- Who loves Kanye, I mean that's
not even a question, is it, right?
It's good question, maybe
we'll try and fit that in.
- [Woman In Front] Tire.
- Yeah, that lady is very adamant
that we'll go with tire.
(crowd laughs)
I, hey, I'll be square with you,
I like the Kanye suggestion,
but changing a tire, it's just because,
you know, I know quite a lot about Kanye,
whereas changing a tire?
I'm like, uh yeah, dad?
How do I find someone who can do this?
Right, okay, this then,
to close out the show,
a real treat for you
guys, is to freestyle rap.
That's a rap made up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions.
It's not ever going to be seen again.
It's made up in the moment,
and it will be about a
history of American racism,
safe pornography usage, changing a tire,
maybe who loves Kanye more
than Kanye, but, maybe not.
Growing up in funeral home,
and what was our other one that we had?
- [Man] Getting cut in line.
- Getting cut in line by a wheelchair.
I was trying to deliberately
forget that one.
I was like, maybe we don't, no.
(crowd laughs)
Cause thing is, I post
these online sometimes
if I like them, and that one's
gonna get me a lot of hate.
- That's okay.
- [Woman in audience] You got this!
Thank you, I love the support.
You're like my Flavor Flav there.
Just like, you can do this.
(crowd claps)
If we can drop the beat, good sir?
Let's have some fun with this.
(Sedivi's "Night Thoughts" plays)
I'm excited.
Oh, and this is a new beat as well.
And more little volume as well.
I don't even know where
the drop is on this one.
I shoulda listened to it before we did it.
Okay, can we rewind it?
I want to hit that drop, Dwayne.
I'm like, super pro.
It's cause I mix up the beat each time,
and then, yeah okay, right.
So, which one to start with?
I'm gonna go with the
lady in the back, yeah.
♪ Lady in the back ♪
♪ Not donned all in black ♪
♪ She could change that attire ♪
♪ If you gave it a crack ♪
♪ Growing up in funeral
home plain to see ♪
♪ A chill lady loving mortuary ♪
♪ Assisting her dad when it
comes to the chloroform ♪
♪ Put formaldehyde there ♪
♪ And I look at all the corpses ♪
♪ Lying up inside the morgue ♪
♪ In the funeral home ♪
♪ Yeah, you feel adored ♪
♪ There's so much death ♪
♪ But so much love as well ♪
♪ Six Feet Under ♪
♪ Cast me in its spell ♪
♪ I watched the television series ♪
♪ With the guy from "Dexter" ♪
♪ Michael C. Hall, yeah ♪
♪ Wikipedia check ya ♪
♪ I know the names like I'm IMDb ♪
♪ When I wake up in the morning ♪
♪ Icy people I see ♪
♪ Dead there, cold to touch ♪
♪ And flowers in the vase ♪
♪ People walking in ♪
♪ All the poor widows ♪
♪ And widowers ♪
♪ Lady in the back is like ♪
♪ This was my childhood ♪
♪ Did you enjoy it? Yeah! ♪
♪ It was wild good ♪
♪ It was amazing ♪
♪ It couldn't have got any sillier ♪
♪ Unless I said you
indulging in necrophilia ♪
♪ But, you didn't do that ♪
♪ Sick in the head ♪
♪ You think you're going in there ♪
♪ And have a date with the dead ♪
♪ A Day of the Dead ♪
♪ Like Día de Muertos in Mexico ♪
♪ A big problem in this country, yo ♪
♪ Racism ♪
♪ More blacks than whites in prison ♪
♪ A real problem ever since the year... ♪
♪ Oh it's...1616 ♪
♪ The first slave ship came across there ♪
♪ Transporting from the Atlantic ♪
♪ A whole nation ♪
♪ Built on the backs of slaves ♪
♪ No reparations even to this very day ♪
♪ The 13th Amendment ♪
♪ Throwing guys in prison ♪
♪ Is basically slavery ♪
♪ Republicans say it isn't ♪
♪ It doesn't matter though ♪
♪ The beat's not long enough ♪
♪ My knowledge of this
history is not strong enough ♪
♪ But, we need to come
at it from all fronts ♪
♪ On the very last day ♪
♪ Of Black History Month ♪
♪ But I'm moving on now ♪
♪ It's what we do ♪
♪ If you're in a wheelchair ♪
♪ Yeah, I get you ♪
♪ It must've sucked ♪
♪ That you lost the use of your legs ♪
♪ It must be horrible ♪
♪ You need a bedpan in your bed ♪
♪ But still ♪
♪ Man, when will you learn ♪
♪ "I've got wheels ♪
♪ And I'm limp", still ♪
♪ Wait your turn ♪
♪ This is a whole damn line ♪
♪ I'm looking at you ♪
♪ You need to wheel right there ♪
♪ To the back of the queue ♪
♪ Everybody feels like you
get the sympathy vote ♪
♪ Now you get concession tickets ♪
♪ Yeah, you get on boats for cheaper ♪
♪ Than everybody else has got to pay ♪
♪ I said it and he cried ♪
♪ I ruined his day ♪
♪ Cause we're at Disneyland ♪
♪ He's only seven years old ♪
♪ Make a Wish child ♪
♪ And I still give him scold-ing ♪
♪ And say Nah ♪
♪ I don't give a fuck ♪
♪ You are not getting to shake ♪
♪ Micky Mouse or Donald Duck's hand ♪
♪ I waited here ♪
♪ He's crying like a fountain ♪
♪ When I'm riding high ♪
♪ Having fun on Space Mountain ♪
♪ The best place for me to be ♪
♪ Let me talk about the rapper ♪
♪ And it's plain to see ♪
♪ He's insane, you know? ♪
♪ He's going off his rocker ♪
♪ Thinks he's amazing and wise ♪
♪ Like Spock there from 'Star Trek' ♪
♪ But I'll say today ♪
♪ No one loves Kanye more
than Kanye loves Kanye ♪
♪ He loves himself ♪
♪ And it is not good ♪
♪ I know these days we
say we need self love ♪
♪ You need to self care ♪
♪ Practice it and take a day off ♪
♪ Nah, Kanye ♪
♪ Really, ask a prof-essor
of mental health ♪
♪ What is wrong with you? ♪
♪ Well they prescribe Lexapro ♪
♪ It's what you do if you're depressed ♪
♪ And suffer from anxiety ♪
♪ Still, 10 years ago ♪
♪ It was easy to proclaim
him as a genius ♪
♪ We can answer me ♪
♪ Best Kanye album? ♪
♪ 'My...Dark Twisted Fantasy' ♪
♪ We know that stuff ♪
♪ Some people say no,
it doesn't please us ♪
♪ It was The...Dropout or Yeezus ♪
♪ We need the one more ♪
♪ I'm holding yours for end ♪
♪ What was the suggestion ♪
♪ We got from these friends? ♪
What was the one that wasn't that one?
- [Woman] Change a tire!
- [Man] Sex Ed!
- Nah, I'm gonna come to
that last, 'cos that's funnier.
This one's less fun.
♪ I would be boasting ♪
♪ I make it up, I'd be a liar ♪
♪ If I said I'd ever encountered
changing the car tires ♪
♪ I just sit there and pull
out my insurance plan ♪
♪ And wait there AAA ♪
♪ For a much better man ♪
♪ He rocks up ♪
♪ He says, Chris, it's not there ♪
♪ I wasn't aware that in my boot ♪
♪ I didn't even have a spare ♪
♪ I drive a BMW 3 Series
with the run-flats ♪
♪ I really worry yeah you know ♪
♪ I shouldn't have done that ♪
♪ I shouldn't have stopped
I should'a drove it home ♪
♪ Put it in the garage ♪
♪ Over here you say garage ♪
♪ And I'm living it large ♪
♪ Cause I'm changing
tires from front to back ♪
♪ I rotate them at the place ♪
♪ they put it on the jack ♪
♪ They lift it up ♪
♪ And then they change
the oil while I wait ♪
♪ Now, guys, take care
every time you masturbate ♪
♪ It's really cool ♪
♪ You gotta educate the kids ♪
♪ So it comes to porn and
they're not addicted ♪
♪ Cause it's so pervasive ♪
♪ You're pulling out your phone ♪
♪ There's pop-ups for advertisements ♪
♪ Wanking off at home ♪
♪ Ladies in your area ♪
♪ Wanna hook up with you ♪
♪ And when you're horny and you're 13 ♪
♪ What the fuck you gonna do? ♪
♪ You gonna get real erect and say ♪
♪ Yeah, ladies, I no longer respect them ♪
♪ Cause my whole idea of sex ♪
♪ Is being turned rough ♪
♪ Because they get it in the
newsfeed so much enough ♪
♪ They see crazy stuff ♪
♪ Like porn that is snuff ♪
♪ That's when you kill someone ♪
♪ when you've had the sex in the buff ♪
♪ That is so crazy ♪
♪ And it can't be easy ♪
♪ To be the person who's
acting as the teacher ♪
♪ Trying to get attention
at the back of the class ♪
♪ They're over there and
they're fucking jacking off ♪
♪ In an ass ♪
♪ It's so horrible ♪
♪ Why would you have to envision that ♪
♪ Coming over here ♪
♪ No, there's no revision of that ♪
♪ It's not homework when
you're home and you jerk ♪
♪ And then you clean it up ♪
♪ After all the kids squirt ♪
♪ And obviously I'm just
focusing on the guys ♪
♪ Because to talk about the ladies ♪
♪ Would not be fair in your eyes ♪
There you go.
(crowd erupts with applause)
[Woman in audience] Oh my God!
(crowd applaud and cheer)
That's basically your curriculum, right?
(crowd laughs)
Can't have curriculum without cum.